digamos que tenemos una reacción de
primer orden en la que nuestro reactivo
se transforma en nuestros productos y
además sabemos cuál es la concentración
del reactivo al tiempo cero y también al
tiempo t ok ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es utilizar lo que sabemos acerca de la
velocidad de cualquier reacción de
primer grado aunque por ejemplo sabemos
que la velocidad promedio de la reacción
se puede escribir como el cambio en la
concentración de a entre el cambio en el
tiempo y cómo es nuestro reactivo y está
desapareciendo
entonces ponemos un menos por aquí para
que la velocidad promedio sea positiva
aunque esto ya lo vimos en un vídeo
pasado ahora por otro lado también
tenemos la ley de la reacción y sabemos
que la velocidad de la reacción es igual
a la constante de velocidad
por la concentración de a elevada a la
primera potencia y ponemos este
exponente porque ya sabemos que esta
reacción es una reacción de primer orden
y también hemos hablado de esto en un
vídeo pasado ahora aquí hay un detalle
muy importante y es el hecho de que esta
es la velocidad de la reacción en un
punto en el tiempo
ok sí tenemos una concentración de a por
ejemplo digamos que es la concentración
de a en el tiempo ese entonces sabemos
cuál es la velocidad de la reacción en
el tiempo ese y por lo tanto está r es
distinta de esta otra no que hay porque
está r es la velocidad promedio de la
reacción que es como si sacáramos el
promedio de todas estas velocidades
instantáneas a lo largo del intervalo de
0 a t aunque entonces no podríamos decir
que son iguales sin embargo sí
el intervalo sobre el cual estamos
tomando todos los promedios si este
incremento en el tiempo lo hiciéramos
cada vez más chico entonces esta
velocidad promedio de reacción se
parecería cada vez más a la velocidad
instantánea de la reacción pero si
hacemos cada vez más chico el incremento
lo que obtenemos es la derivada macri
haciendo el incremento de t cada vez más
chico lo que obtenemos es la derivada de
la concentración de a con respecto al
tiempo y por aquí tenemos un signo menos
y ahora si esta derivada es igual a la
velocidad de la reacción que como
tenemos aquí en la ley de la velocidad
de esta reacción de primer orden la
velocidad de la reacción es igual a la
constante de velocidad por la
concentración de a elevada a la primera
potencia y tenemos esta igualdad para
cualquier punto en el tiempo y como aquí
tenemos
derivada esto se llama una ecuación
diferencial que si podemos resolver y
cuando resolvemos esta ecuación
diferencial lo que vamos a obtener es la
concentración de a como una función del
tiempo aunque vamos a obtener la
concentración de a como función del
tiempo también lo tenemos por aquí
para resolver esta ecuación diferencial
lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
separar las variables si es que tenemos
que poner a todo lo que involucre a la
concentración de a de un lado de la
igualdad y a lo que involucra el tiempo
en el otro lado entonces vamos a dividir
de los dos lados del igual entre la
concentración de a y la verdad es que
queremos poner el diferencial de t del
lado derecho no podemos decir que
multiplicamos por el diferencial de t
pero pues esta ecuación si es
equivalente a la que voy a poner a
continuación de concentración de a entre
la concentración de a
es igual a menos menos k
por dt d
y ahora ya estamos listos para integrar
entonces vamos a integrar esto con
respecto a la concentración de a y de
este lado vamos a integrar con respecto
al tiempo aunque hay pero como acá es
una constante con respecto al tiempo
puede salir de la integral y ahora
tenemos que poner los límites de
integración y vamos a utilizar estos
límites de integración
aquí estamos integrando con respecto al
tiempo entonces vamos a integrar de 0 a
t que integramos de 0 a t y por acá
vamos a integrar con respecto a la
concentración de a y cuando el tiempo es
igual a cero el tiempo es igual a cero
la concentración de a es igual a la
concentración de a en el tiempo cero
entonces por aquí tenemos que integrar
desde la concentración de a
en el tiempo cero hasta la concentración
de a en el tiempo de concentración de a
en el tiempo t
ya esto generalmente le llamamos la
concentración inicial y esta es la
concentración de a en cierto tiempo t
entonces ya estamos listos para la
integración podemos identificar aquí que
esta es la derivada del logaritmo
natural entonces la integral va a ser el
logaritmo natural de la concentración de
a
que es nuestra variable evaluada desde
la concentración inicial de
hasta la concentración de a en el tiempo
de concentración de a en el tiempo te
por aquí tenemos un igual tenemos menos
acá menos
y luego esta integral es simplemente
está evaluada desde cero hasta t desde
cero hasta t y para hacer esto lo que
hicimos fue utilizar el teorema
fundamental del cálculo
y ahora ya nada más tenemos que evaluar
estas expresiones en estos límites ahí
tenemos el logaritmo natural evaluado en
la concentración de a al tiempo que el
logaritmo natural de la concentración de
a evaluada al tiempo t - menos el
logaritmo natural evaluado en la
concentración de a al tiempo inicial
logaritmo natural de la concentración de
a el tiempo cero y esto es igual a menos
acá
por t evaluada en t o sea menos 0 pero
bueno eso no lo vamos a poner porque es
un 0 y entonces ya obtuvimos la ley de
velocidad integrada a cabo al menos una
forma de describirla aunque esta es la
ecuación para las reacciones de primer
orden que es la ley de velocidad
integrada para reacciones de primer
orden y pues podemos seguir y escribir
la de otra forma pero esta ecuación es
muy útil para calcular algunas cosas
como vamos a ver que ahí vamos a seguir
adelante vamos a reescribir la ley de
velocidad integrada pero vamos a poner
ahora el logaritmo de la concentración
inicial de a del otro lado del igual acá
y sumamos logaritmo natural de la
concentración inicial de a de los dos
lados del igual y lo que nos queda es
que el logaritmo natural de la
concentración de a en el tiempo t
es igual a menos que por el tiempo más
el logaritmo natural de la concentración
de a al tiempo inicial y la razón por la
que yo quería reescribir esta ecuación
de esta forma es para que sea súper
claro que aquí lo que tenemos es la
ecuación de una recta porque si tenemos
la concentración de a inicial o sea en
el tiempo fijo cero entonces esto de
aquí es una constante con respecto al
tiempo y tenemos el tiempo multiplicado
por un coeficiente y entonces esta es la
ecuación de una recta aunque aquí
podemos ponernos a pensar que igual a m
x
ve mx más ve es la gráfica de una línea
recta y si quisiéramos graficar esto de
aquí en el eje h
pondríamos a logaritmo natural de la
concentración de gente y luego en el eje
x pondríamos a t kioto y entonces la
pendiente de esta recta es menos acá y
luego la ordenada al origen la
intersección con el eje es el logaritmo
natural de la concentración de a al
tiempo cero
ok entonces vamos a graficar lo por aquí
tenemos el eje de y por acá tenemos el
eje x en el eje y vamos a colocar el
logaritmo natural de la concentración de
al tiempo t y en el eje x vamos a
colocar el tiempo entonces a la hora de
graficar esto nos va a quedar una línea
recta
digamos que empezamos por aquí y nos
vamos en línea recta hasta acá y este
punto de aquí es la ordenada al origen
entonces esta altura debe de ser el
logaritmo natural de la concentración de
a en cero
ok esta altura es el logaritmo natural
de la concentración inicial de a y la
pendiente de la recta es igual a menos
acá entonces la pendiente de esta recta
es igual a menos que lo que haya menos
la constante de velocidad
entonces la gráfica del logaritmo
natural de la concentración de a con
respecto al tiempo es una línea recta
cuya pendiente es igual a menos la
constante de velocidad de la reacción y
como vamos a ver en el próximo vídeo
saber esto es muy útil para poder
calcular la constante de velocidad a
partir de datos experimentales acerca de
la concentración de a